The Last of Us was all about trying to
put the player as much as possible into
that grounded reality of Joel and Ellie
as a survivor in that world and we
really constrained ourselves on design
art etc and then uncharted coming back
to it's like oh man cool I can like jump
I remember on uncharted 2 we like kind
of just start figuring out set pieces
and how to get to set pieces on the
stake so you're really playing through a
collapsing building or sliding platform
finding a helicopter and then you know
moving on to the last of us we're kind
of really concerned with how do we take
those set pieces make it more intimate
but make them really parallel the story
and the character arcs and now coming
back to and charters like okay we can go
epic again we go big but we're really
challenging ourselves like again how do
we mirror the character art so we're
taking what we've learned from one tried
to evolved it to last of us and bringing
it back but we're still keeping that
pacing the rollercoaster but at the same
time it has to be driven by what's
happening with the characters at that
moment I don't really have an option
here you know that
yeah maybe you're right I've been out of
the game I need back in it the last of
us we went to great lengths to try to
create this reality but we were still
limited by the amount of overdraw the
ps3 could handle etc and now the ps4 is
allowing us to push so much more density
so it's fun to go back and go like oh
look at the things we wish we could have
done in uncharted 1 it's just like oh
this is easy like let's just make this
so it's nice to be able to explore
something look back and go wow this is
like remember when we couldn't do any of
this it's kind of neat from a character
standpoint the tech really allowed us to
get more subtlety and you're seeing
hints of that you know in the trailer
how much we could show pain or grimaces
or you know it's a subtle touch but like
as he raises his eyebrows you know like
the color of your skin changes as the
blood flows away from that compression
and all those things just let a
realistic character become much more
ground and much more believable gameplay
wise we're just going deeper and richer
with all the mechanics it's still gonna
be a roller coaster ride it's still
gonna have that pacing we still want you
on the edge of your seat but at the same
time we want to make sure that you as
player as I as a player I want to play
this thing and feel invested and we want
to make sure we have that with the epic
with the pacing with the characters that
we're known for and our motto and
uncharted 2 was always keep it core no
matter how big the set piece gets keep
it on the control stick keep the core
system so taking that into uncharted 4
is like okay knowing we want to keep it
core how do we expand Nate of core moves
it how do we build more systems that
will give the player more options more
ways to kind of approach whether it's
exploration traversal or combat you're
gonna have more ways to attack those
things ultimately I think it will come
down to how good is the gameplay how
good is the story because without that
you know you can have all the graphical
bells and whistles and it doesn't matter
but if you have this really strong
foundation those things can really help
to take over the top and we're gonna get
you immersed in this journey from
uncharted 1 all the way through for each
journey dovetails into the next so we've
taken that chronology and the storylines
and and the relationships and just kind
of evolved them into this next journey
and you
see got a little bit of gray feathers
ring inside of his hair now got the good
crow's feet over on the I like I have
you know it's like we're all aging with
Nathan Drake so can I count on you